there are over 7 billion people living
on the earth right now tens of millions
are born and die each year every single
one of us leaves signs of our existence
in the air water soil even space but
these signs won't last forever our
buildings will be gone in a few hundred
years our stone monuments plastic
styrofoam twinkies even evidence of our
inevitable nuclear destruction will
eventually be gone so how can we be sure
that we were the first advanced
civilization on earth well according to
the silurian hypothesis
we can't let's find out why
[Music]
let's talk about the silurian hypothesis
what the hell is a solution well they
were intelligent humanoid reptilians who
in an episode of doctor who were
awakened by nuclear testing after 400
million years of hibernation blizzard
people yep we're finally doing a lizard
people episode we are
well kinda humans are selfish it's hard
for us to imagine that in a very short
time we as individuals won't be here and
it's even harder to imagine a time where
our civilization won't exist at all but
if we learned anything from archaeology
it's that every civilization has its
time think about ancient egypt they
lived 30 dynasties that spanned over 3
000 years and if you were an egyptian
living during this time
generations of your family going back as
far as anyone can remember walked in the
shadow of the pyramids they fished the
nile they sailed the mediterranean
mingled with other cultures as far as
you or anyone knew your civilization had
been there and would last forever
then it was gone the mesopotamians
before them the indus after them greeks
nubians the persians romans incas aztecs
these were empires of millions of people
all lasting a thousand years or more but
very little evidence of them remains now
all of these civilizations including our
own modern one have only been here for a
short time complex life has existed for
hundreds of millions of years modern
humans have only been here for about 100
000 years our entire history has taken
place in the past
0.002 percent of life on earth so
there's a whole lot of past in the past
and that's plenty of time for other
intelligent species to evolve thrive and
go extinct over and over again with
different species
and if that happened would we really
know they were here when adam frank and
gavin schmidt wrote the silurian
hypothesis they addressed a lot of
misconceptions about how we study the
past we're used to the idea that we
learn of ancient societies by examining
artifacts and excavated ruins
but this really only works if you're
going back a few thousand years but when
you want to go back millions of years
it's more complicated for example the
earth is about 4.5 billion years old and
complex life appeared about 600 million
years ago fine but the oldest surface
land ever discovered is the negev desert
in israel it's about 1.8 million years
old that's it
every other piece of exposed land we've
ever found is newer than that so
where'd all the land go
[Music]
if ancient civilizations existed before
humans they could be very hard to detect
because of the earth's plate tectonics
today's mountains are yesterday's ocean
floor new land is formed every day as
old lands are eroded into dust that's
why discovering fossils is a lot more
difficult than people think very
specific conditions need to be present
for fossilization the organism needs
hard body parts like bones teeth and
shells the remains need to be quickly
covered and protected from scavenging
and erosion you need high pressure for
mineralization and low oxygen to prevent
decomposition this almost never happens
dinosaurs roam the earth for about 180
million years
trillions of individual animals lived
and died yet we only have a few thousand
near complete fossils it's estimated
that over two and a half billion
tyrannosaurus rex's lived and died on
the earth but fewer than 100 fossils
have ever been found and only one of
them is complete that means we've only
discovered 0.0000
zero
zero four percent of the species
now schmidt and frank said that a
species as short-lived as homo sapiens
might not be represented in the existing
fossil record at all now the current
area of urbanization is less than one
percent of the earth's surface so human
artifacts like road cities machines even
mega structures would last only a few
thousand years and are unlikely to ever
be found
they conclude that direct evidence like
this can only go back about 4 million
years even if the entire human race were
eliminated by a nuclear war the
radioactive evidence would disappear
eventually so are there other methods
for detecting the existence of advanced
intelligent life in the distant past
turns out there are
[Music]
civilization at least as defined by the
authors of the silurian hypothesis is
where industrialization occurs on a
global scale as ours does now as we
speak industrialization is leaving clues
of our existence that will be detectable
by scientists a hundred million years in
the future now eventually our time on
earth will be crushed down to nothing
more than a thin layer of rock sediment
yeah that's uplifting now in a
sedimentary core a layer of a few
centimeters is deposited every thousand
years and in those centimeters future
paleontologists will find evidence of
our geologic era called the anthropocene
now for example we grow so much food now
that our use of fertilizer is actually
redirecting the planet's nitrogen supply
and this nitrogen cycling is also
changing its isotopic signature and this
isotope will be detectable in the
sediment agriculture and deforestation
increase soil erosion and that erosion
washes into the sea and becomes part of
the sediment a human mining activities
have increased the amounts of gold lead
chromium platinum and other metals and
these also will be visible in the
sediment at greater rates than before
but the element that will really tell
the story of civilization is carbon
humans conquered the planet by
harnessing combustion and it seems
reasonable that intelligent life forms
everywhere would do the same thing when
we burn the tissue of long dead plants
fossil fuels we change the ratio of
isotopes in the atmosphere and this is
called the seuss effect the green omelet
guy differences yeah carbon comes in 15
flavors but the most common isotopes are
carbon 12 carbon 13 and carbon 14.
carbon 12 is light carbon this is the
isotope preferred by plants and used
during photosynthesis and animals that
eat plants consume the plants carbon-12
and animals that eat animals that eat
plants consume their carbon-12 and so on
now volcanic emissions are carbon-13
carbon-14 is radioactive and decays
predictably over time fossil fuels have
no carbon-14 at all and as we burn more
fossil fuels the levels of carbon 13 and
14 go down while the level of enriched
carbon 12 goes up all this carbon in the
atmosphere also causes the earth to warm
slightly
what global warming is a myth it's not
sheep
look you can argue that the warming is
man-made or that it's not but either way
we're up about a degree
anyway when looking through sedimentary
layers from millions of years ago this
is what we need to see to determine if
there was an advanced civilization
present we need to see a large but
temporary spike in carbon and oxygen
a large but temporary spike in metals
and a large but temporary spike in
global temperature
we find that
we're on to something have we found that
have we
we have and it happened 56 million years
ago the age of the lizard people
[Music]
a sudden global change of carbon and
oxygen isotope levels happened 56
million years ago in what's known as the
paleocene-eocene thermal maximum or
p-e-t-m and the p-e-t-m only lasted
about two hundred thousand years now
that's nothing in geologic time but
remember that's as long as we've been
here and during this time the petm the
earth's temperature rose about six
degrees celsius now that was warm i mean
we're talking t-shirt weather at the
north pole warm i mean the ice caps were
completely gone lizard people do like
warm weather
what lizard people are cold-blooded
hello read a science book there there
were no lizard people
so is the p-e-t-m evidence of an ancient
civilization yep
probably not it took 5 000 years to
reach the level of carbon in the
atmosphere that we've done in only 300
years so what caused it nobody knows
the best guess is the petm was caused by
a massive volcanic eruption but nobody
knows for sure
what's weird though is there is evidence
of a lot of fossil carbon in the
atmosphere lazy people gas stations and
a few million years later these
conditions happened again and this event
is called the eocene layers of
mysterious origins sounds like the name
of a harry potter book it does and there
were other massive events in the
cretaceous period that depleted the
earth's oceans of oxygen for thousands
of years now to be honest most
scientists believe that we are the first
civilization but they do admit that if
an advanced species only existed for as
long as we have they would be really
hard to detect even the authors of the
silurian hypothesis admit if you're not
specifically looking at the right time
in history and for the right details
you'll probably miss it but the silurian
hypothesis does give us an interesting
set of tools tools that might not help
us find ancient civilizations on our
planet but could help us find them on
other planets
the drake equation is a well-known
formula for estimating the number of
extraterrestrial civilizations in our
galaxy it boils down to the number of
stars that have planets the number of
planets that can support life the
fraction of those planets that develop
life and the fraction of those that can
develop intelligent life now this number
fluctuates as new discoveries are made
but still the number of civilizations
out there could be anywhere from 150 000
to 1.5 billion even if it's just more
than one it would be so cool so cool
what's interesting is now that we had
the silurian hypothesis any planet that
can develop intelligent life can maybe
develop it again and again over millions
or billions of years and that was the
original premise of frank and schmidt's
paper they wondered not only about life
on other planets in the galaxy but about
civilizations that may have existed
right here in our solar system at one
time mars was much wetter and much
warmer so was venus one of jupiter's
moons europa is covered by a saltwater
ocean when we finally get core samples
from these planets we may realize that
those civilizations don't exist there
right now the distant past could tell a
very different story now the authors of
the silurian hypothesis don't believe
there are ancient civilizations on earth
for humans and our civilization may be
unique in the universe but they do lay
out an exciting possibility that there
could be millions of civilizations out
there and now we have the tools to find
them
[Music]
thank you so much for hanging out with
us today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment and share trying
to solve the youtube algorithm is like
trying to discover ancient civilizations
lazy people
but with your help
we can do it until next time be safe be
kind and know that you are appreciated
[Music]
you